the gulf of gokova in southwest turkey
is renowned for its marine biodiversity
one part of the bay is a breeding ground
for sandbar sharks an endangered species
but invasive species like rabbit fish
are a growing threat to the fragile
local ecosystem
rabbit fish as an individual it doesn't
tread any other fish but entire
ecosystem once they graze the
all macroalgae it's all barren we lose
so much biodiversity because other
fishes larvaes or other small juveniles
you know invertebrates small shrimps
shells they're all hiding living under
this microalgae
a further problem besetting the gulf of
gokova is overfishing
samiha barshak's husband died over 10
years ago since then she's had to earn
her own living
but she's up against big fishing
trawlers
they don't leave me anything they come
here with their great big boats and take
everything
20 years ago i used to catch 20 to 30
kilos of fish now i'm happy if i net two
to three kilos
six areas of the bay are now protected
fishing is forbidden
the zones are maintained by a turkish
ngo called the mediterranean
conservation society
zafar kizil kaya counts the fish in the
protected areas at regular intervals
also calculating their biomass to see
whether stocks have been replenished
since the fishing ban was introduced
the results show us exactly what we
towed
this is has this area has the higher
fish biomass
so it's approximately 60 grams per
square meter this is more than you know
six times more
more
than the beginning
welcome on board
the ngo has also come up with another
project to boost the livelihoods of
local fishermen and women
they now offer excursions in their
fishing vessels to tourists
and they take a cut of the proceeds
they want to be on the water they want
to be on the sea on the boat and this is
what they are doing
and they are making money
showing their cultural life
and you know
some interesting part of fishing in the
gerkawa bay to tourists
and once the fishermen and women no
longer depend on their catches to earn
their living the bay's biodiversity has
a better chance of surviving